[Music]
Hornby while now I can't say
I'm just going crazy by CeeLo cuz I'm
crazy as heck he knows who he knows
exactly how crazy I get my son down here
mama crazy singing oh my god I like I
think it's crazy
[Music]
this is more than one question okay it
goes
some call it man
some think is true I don't know this is
it
is it I know you're waiting to be saved
but the show goes on alright already the
show goes on all night
[ __ ] that's a hard one
I guess strangers by the kinks it's all
about like being brothers and that kind
of thing and I have older brothers I'm
really close with sure we'll go stronger
by Britney Spears well you know stronger
than I was yesterday so I'll juggle eggs
hold on let me think about it
my loneliness ain't killing me no more
because pretty much saying that no
matter what happened life goes on
meaning very motivational and asks stuff
to do with when I'm dealing with right
now
diva by Beyonce because I'm the female
version of a hustla haters give me them
salty looks Larry's 50 so me go here
it's like the style up and if they hate
to let them hate and watch the money
pile up and it expresses me because I
just moved to San Diego and I'm living
the good life that's just how it is the
song that best describes me he's living
on a prayer by Bon Jovi why because
every Thursday we pray for healing in
Buffalo Park dark was the night by Blind
Willie Johnson
I connect both to the music of the song
and the energy of the song so it's it's
instrumental working for the weekend
because I work way too much cuz I'm a
teacher
everybody's working for the weekend
Danone the only song I can think of
right now is California for fun some
planets because we've been obsessed with
the show a couple of years ago and it
was vo C and is it's been a dream for us
to come here in California
[Music]
House of the Rising Sun the story of my
life it seems to resonate with what I've
done and where I've been
by Jenny why why because it's like it's
slow steady but it has a good rhythm and
I guess like me it's just that's classic
okay I'm just dancing looking fine so
what song best describes me it depends
on who I am for the day I guess never
going back nicely went back it's been on
my mind lately
why I've been thinking a lot about like
the idea of like nostalgia like
returning to something they know it's
always a question whether things
remember we're actually ever the way
they were so maybe we're always trying
to go back to things that never really
existed you don't know what it means to
win and that's my favorite line from the
song I like big butts by Sir mix-a-lot
and obviously my favorite line is the
main line I like big butts and I cannot
lie oh that's a tough one
yes good comeback next week I have
answer three AM matchbox 20 yeah
now you get to like Karen back off think
about it I just picked one and I'm like
you said it's a connection you said
you'll have to like actually describe
you it's more of a connection to that
song it's one of those songs you play
and you always feel good I would have to
say drops of Jupiter because it's always
been my go-to song when I've been super
depressed now that she's back in the
atmosphere drops of Jupiter in her hands
oh my god there's so many songs um good
life by OneRepublic
because I just like the message how no
matter what circumstance you're in or
what is going on around you and be good
like oh it's gonna be a good life a good
good life it's route it's I don't
remember what's the name of band it's
fine gonna be so
my way by Frank Sinatra just because
like doing things my way I just called
to say I love you by Stevie Wonder my
dad used to call me just randomly me and
my mom and he used to just say he loves
us and it just reminds me memories I
just called to say
I love you I just called to say how much
I care I just call to say I love you my
cold sucks but I hope your movies great
by Bobby Caldwell it's a what you won't
do for love
and subscribe I think I describes me
because I pass relationships or
relationships you know I do a lot of
things for people and you know but they
won't do it back you know but you won't
do you do for love you tried everything
but you don't give up in my world only
you make me do for love what you would
not do
I feel like single ladies
describe me
I'm single Oh single ladies put your
hands up that's true yelling government
broke is a getting paid tomorrow but
right now I'm broken I'm 19
young dumb broke high school kids were
here Eggman
Paul's Boutique Beastie Boys because
I'll waste anybody with a dick in my
hand
no promises by Demi Lovato because I'm
spontaneous never in one place at any
point in time
oh nana just be careful Nana
loving simple man promise me no promises
it would be the friends theme song
because it's like well first off it's
like really catchy and I'm like always
singing along to it and then the second
is because like it's talking about like
friendship and how like you always have
to be there for like friends and how
they have to be there for you and I know
friends are like the most important
people in my life so so no one told you
life was gonna be this way your jobs a
joke you're broke your love life to your
way it's like you're always stuck in
second gear when it hasn't been your day
a week a month or even your year but
I'll be there for you which the rain
starts to pour I'll be there for you cuz
I've been there before
could be there for me doo-doo-doo-doo
I seen the whole thing
[Music]